I Saw The Light inside
[Music]
American Idol judges are honoring the
light they saw in season 19 runner-up
Willie Spence who died Tuesday in a car
accident at the age of 23.
for you to go back to your hometown
and you see the people that grew up with
you look at you a different way
and they look at you with pride and
inspiration because if you can do this
it's inspiring for everyone else to be
able to say I can do it Lionel Richie
posted a video on Instagram of one of
Willie's performances alongside a
heartfelt caption quote your light will
always shine in this world we were so
blessed to get a chance to see you shine
my thoughts and prayers are with
Willie's family rest well my friend
thank you so much to all my supporters I
don't even call them fans I call them my
supporters you know Luke Bryan praised
Willie for the star he was writing quote
Willie really did light up every room he
walked into he could change the mood
instantly when he started singing he
will truly be missed
man
what Joy you bring my heart and my soul
meanwhile Katy Perry simply honored
Willie's memory by sharing a video on
her Instagram stories
and it's clear the entire American Idol
family is grieving the show's official
Twitter account posted a statement that
their quote devastated by Willie's death
an addict quote he was a true Talent Who
lit up every room he entered and will
deeply be missed we send our condolences
to his loved ones I growed up watching
American Idol used to play the American
Idol video games on the Wii so to
actually be able to sing on the actual
American Idol stage is an honor and I'm
just glad to be a part when it comes to
the singer's untimely death new
information is emerging about the car
accident that took his life according to
ABC News affiliate wjcl in Georgia
Willy's home state he was driving on the
interstate in Tennessee around 4 pm on
Tuesday when he exited the roadway
Tennessee Highway Patrol says a
tractor-trailer was stopped on the
shoulder and Willie who was wearing a
seat belt collided with it the tractor
operator was reportedly not injured
[Music]
foreign
[Music]